اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان مرينا
في شيء
الله لا يرويكم ان شاء الله الحمد لله
الله يحفظنا وستر علينا
فجاه صار الموضوع يعني انا قمت السرير
يهتز كل شيء قاعد يطيح
وتشهد يمكن فوق العشرين مره جالس اتشهد
الين ما استوعبت انه لا لا الوضع صدعني
اي والله
ركيض والغرفه
الحاله حاله والله انا ما اقدر ما اقدر
اوصف لك الحين المشهد لانه للان عايشين
احنا في صدمه والله
منظر يروع والله اتمنى ما حد يعيشه والله
السلام عليكم طبعا
الان عقب الزلزال وعقب الكارثه اللي صارت
في تركيا جنه عند الملاجئ اللي موجوده بعد
تجمع اهالي المنطقه ونحاول طبعا نوصل لهم
هذه المساعدات العاجله
الاحتياجات الضروريه والاساسيه وان شاء
الله نوصل الى اكثر من ملجا وهذي كلها
طبعا تحركات قطر الخيريه العاجله في تركيا